Lisa bloom who's a liberal attorney
that's represented women who've accused
men in high places of sexual harassment
apparently according to the hill who've
seen the documentation Lisa bloom sought
to line up paydays for women accusing
Trump of sexual misconduct during the
last final months of the campaign and
she worked with the tabloids and
campaign donors and was getting like a
ridiculous cut when she would sell these
stories to the tabloids does this at all
undermine the credibility of some of the
Trump accusers because I know we've
heard a lot about that recently Lisa
bloom tries to explain all of this
as to why she was trying to help the
women because they might have to get a
private security they might lose their
job and it'd be a bad financial position
I know that if you have a problem that
you think you want to bring to either
your boss or to the media I would not
use Lisa blooms representation yeah I
think that that she's a pastor sell by
date but it's not what you said which is
that it's there for evidence that
somehow these women are not to be
believed or they were out there making
up stories to say it well I just think
you asked the question the question but
it's not I mean what it is is that
people oftentimes will try to monetize
these kind of scandals and I think even
our president had a relationship with
the National Enquirer okay yeah people
do look for paydays but I mean if you're
shopping it around I have a payday right
here no I had it my pockets is yesterday
scandal by purchasing this candy bar and
leaving it in my pocket and I bet it's
delicious I might add that it is another
example of transparency the things that
you learn under a trump presidency
you'll see the cronyism and the
corruption but you'll also see that this
legal dirty trickery that we've never
seen before we've learned if we've
learned anything from 2016 and 2017
nothing is what it seems and if you just
wait just wait a couple of weeks you're
gonna find that we're looking at a lot
of a lot of interesting scandals and you
just wait and then it turns out it's
something else completely and you
realize that you she was against Trump
but for Weinstein yeah
payroll better disavow and say okay I'm
not gonna work for Weinstein anymore so
I don't know it's getting a little messy
not only was she working with what
Weinstein but she was actively seeking
to destroy the reputations of some of
the women that want Weinstein's behest
even her mother didn't like that
no what's your mother's name Laura
Allred all right